im winter vor zwei jahren steigen die
preise für schweizer export waren über
nacht massiv weil die nationalbank
überraschend ihre geldpolitik ändern
die schweizerische nationalbank hat
beschlossen den mindestkurs von einem
franken 20 pro euro per sofort
aufzuheben und ihn nicht mehr mit der
wissen käufen durchzusetzen
der ausstieg aus einer solchen politik
erfolgt überraschend genauso wie die
einstieg überraschend war muss
zwangsläufig der ausstieg aus einen
mindestkurs politik überraschend fordern
[Musik]
nationalbank aufgrund des mit einem
schlag schweizer wach platz
tourismusland russland gegen russland
insbesondere gegenüber dem euro land
swiss tools im emmental ist eine von
vielen firmen die mit der frankenstärke
kämpfen
sie und zwei andere haben zugesagt dass
wir ringen mit der preissteigerung
beobachten dürfen nun keine
selbstverständlichkeit
dutzende von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen sogenannte kmu sollten ihre
probleme keinesfalls öffentlich zeigen
es sind das familienunternehmen
generation von der familie geführt wurde
operativ geführt wurde sieht rund zwei
jahren wichtig uns group leiten
laut vita mehrere 1600 meter sind trumpf
und die schweiz statik und recht
beschäftigen mehr in osteuropa china und
vertriebsorganisationen ein grund ganz
land innerhalb der schulter gruppe ist
christian holz gang für die schweiz
zuständig der hauptsitz ist in warth
wichtig auf herstellung von
elektronischen komponenten das können
sie schalten sich gesteckt aber auch
elektronik platine bestücken und so
weiter nachdem nationalbank entscheid
heißt die bange frage wie weiter eine
große unsicherheit ob sie
außerordentliche krisensitzung
das ist der fehlende betrag erhöht sowie
ist praktisch wenn man die maßnahme
würde machen hat entschieden dass mit
brüssel hat die dritte schweizer meine
das ist verstärkt ist mir also forschte
im steigen ist und dass es mir wie viel
stellen wie viele mitarbeiter davon
betroffen
also eigentlich bis nicht die 60 bis 115
bis an die mit geschäfte bis an die 15
zusätzliches potenzial denn bis mit des
achters ins victory 7 und bis an die 16
26 exklusive liegt verfügung sentry 2 1
karlsplatz
alle fahrzeuge zusammen wirklich
kritisch damit dass sozialpartner nach
solchen zeiten wir möchten natürlich
sind sie bei uns ist man wirklich gebaut
das im nachhinein
das szenario ist düster zehn prozent der
arbeitsplätze stehen auf dem spiel
zwei bayerische familienunternehmen ich
mache das in dritter generation
die vorfahren das unternehmen 1902
gegründet wir sehen jetzt am ersten
september 84 jahre alt gesehen wir
machen elektrische grad spezielle
explosionsgeschützte ich wo man vor wenn
die chemie fahrens technik in
raffinerien auf provinzler im flugzeug
unterhalt der bus der flugzeugproduktion
wir sind 63 sie gilt der standort im
ausland spielt und dann haben wir unsere
partner russland wenn man den
unternehmen verkaufsgesellschaften
beteiligt sind
in schanghai in kuala lumpur in abu
dhabi und neue jetzt neu mumbai wir
haben natürlich schlagartig wie man sehr
viele mario machen eigentlich bald mit
mit ausschluss verschieden auch in us
dollar geschaffen haben die schlagartig
mehr oder weniger 17 bis 20 deshalb
versucht peter thurnherr neue
geschäftsfelder zu eröffnen
zum beispiel feuerwehrboote ausgerüstet
mit seinen leuchtend
wir hatten die möglichkeit dieses boot
mit explosionsgeschützte material
auszustatten
die kontrollelemente und beleuchtung
alles explosionsgeschützte
und damit eine neue rolle tragen sie
wesentlich mehr lehrern im zusammenhang
mit dem hohen gewicht zu fragen kann ich
das jahr weit vor den elementen abstiege
nation und größer vergünstigung
hervorrief und so dass man applikationen
findet am thema bis jetzt nicht an um
dort neue geschäftsfelder zu entwickeln
ja das thema der schluss war aber so
eine rolle dienen und vorteil für die
offerte nicht dass sie selber in blogs
die nimmt kurz licht geht damit wenn die
darbietung nach den schafen dass sie
nirgends gesehen und explosionsschutz
die explosionsstelle sich also wenn sie
jetzt ein tankschiff mit avery plane
fahrer hatte man am brenner darf nicht
passieren und moment wie youtube
ich wiederhole es normal ist ganz ganz
wichtig stichwort ihr name schließlich
bisio und familienmitglied vor der
familie baumann war jetzt die vierte
generation die firma für babys willst du
es ist eigentlich es wurde eine
exklusive schweizer kreuz und auf der
anderen seite sind aber sicher zum
tricks nicht noch mehr würden wir hier
immer mit 1000 und august produkt hier
vor ort eine zwei produktionswerke
produzieren sondern
[Musik]
wer hier ganz wesentliche rosso woche
und mehr hier belegschaft wo sich erst
sehr loyal verhalten gegenüber der firma
saubere und auf der anderen seite
op-tisch laufende qualifikation mitte
muss bauer innovationskraft halten und
der andere sieht auch wir kochen lassen
sie vermisse partner weltweit das
bedingt dass jede mitarbeiterin jeder
mitarbeiter
das beste zum schluss einfach die
qualität oft an regeln halten
[Musik]
mitarbeiter information kurz nachdem
nationalbank entscheid dann sehen ich
muss klarheit für sich blanik einfluss
geschäftsentwicklung und die ganz
wichtige frage wie reagieren wir jetzt
aufgrund von der neuen ausgangslage
alt bundesrätin ruth metzler kennt die
probleme sie ist heute präsident in der
spitzel and global enterprise im auftrag
des bundes unterstützt sie
exportorientierte unternehmen die
maßnahme machte die vergangenheit und
versucht möglichst was arbeitsplatz
mäßig verschiedene betriebe unverzüglich
jetzt passiert ist dass wir mit der
belegschaft sei für die bahn gemacht
zeitungsseite länger vor allem aber
dürfte experience sie sind dass der
betrag von der box ist dass jede stunde
pro woche geschafft und das hat mich es
wirkt als ganzes schönes und kurzzeichen
punkt platz schweizer mittelland sind
alle im gleichen boot und diese
mitarbeiten hey wie immer ist auch
absolut loyal verhalten und zwölf
stunden geschafft und als auch die ganze
belegschaft zu bekommen
die zusatz nach zwölf stunden pro woche
zum blicken und das natürlich in rom
unterstützt
dem ist ja schon länger schlafen sogar
früchte und örtlichen bauern zu worden
ich bin ich kommen die forscher zu dem
schluss dass das mini pro
hallo
verloren
der schwule
gegenüber der swiss tools produziert die
verpackungsfirma mopac sie geriet wegen
des chors schocks sind schwierigkeiten
ihre produkte waren nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig von 155 mitarbeitern
verloren 95 ihre stelle interviews lehnt
mubarak ab
also das ist natürlich sehr
besorgniserregend wenn arbeitgeber und
somit waldwasser schlussendlich große
anzahl steht und auch kündigungen
aussprechen das ist verunsichert
das ganze dorf für meine familie hier
vor ort
stephan krähenbühl hatte bis vor kurzem
bei mobook gearbeitet
wie immer bot wie fade und sie sich an
den klassiker
die großen dass die csu nicht
dies kann ganz einfach dem jahre job zu
finden
momentan wird im moment ja schon
[Musik]
stefan krempl ist mittags zu hause bei
der familie wie viele als historisch
auch ehefrau therese krähenbühl arbeitet
in der firma
[Musik]
der andere situation hier für arbeit
für peter thurnherr ist das personal
sein kapital entlassungen kommen nicht
in farbe
lieber nimmt hier vorübergehend verluste
in kauf dass ich überhaupt kein
diskussionspunkt
umso mehr dass wir sehr großer wert auf
schule kläger in der vergangenheit als
sehr viel geld investiert dann in unser
personal glück kann durch das
familienunternehmen sind langjährige
mitarbeiter zwar bis über 30 jahren
firma treue halten
[Musik]
unterwegs in tschechien mit ralf müller
von der schulter gruppe schulte will wie
eine neue fabrik alle aus dem boden
stampfen
eine konsequenz aus dem national bank in
gedanken für alternative gibt um amerika
erfolg und ein hobby oder und schüttet
dass mir das fast täglich um 100 prozent
fussball
[Musik]
das bedeutet über 200 neue stellen ihr
in der nähe von prag rund 40 prozent
mehr stunden bringen
im web die 200 personen der produktion
sie um der vierziger trauben
installation 240 personen und das
wirklich schweiz entsprechend ab da bin
ich das noch nicht so klar
neid das ist also mit details zum
verweilen zum teil sachen sind sache wo
haupt masse gemacht wartet sachen wo man
die sechs länder wie griechenland wieder
werte selbermachen und dreiteilig
natürlich genauer kompensation wo zurück
schon bald werden hier also maschinen
aus der schweiz stehen
die lage ist prekär die probleme
offensichtlich
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zu diesem
mediengespräch im dezember erwartete die
snb für 2015 ein jahreswachstum von rund
zwei prozent diese prognose musste
angesichts der seit mitte januar
erfolgten aufwertung des frankens
revidiert werden
insbesondere im ersten halbjahr ist mit
einer spürbaren abschwächung der
wirtschaftsentwicklung zu rechnen
aufgrund dieser entwicklung ist
kurzfristig mit einer deutlichen
unterauslastung der
produktionskapazitäten zu rechnen
die arbeitslosigkeit dürfte moderat
ansteigen
auch swiss tools zitiere konsequenz aus
dem kurs jörg der maschinenpark wird
gezügelt statt zwei
produktionsstandorten gibt es nur noch
einen
die erträge sind zusammengebrochen
wie gesagt ist und wie sie mit in die
stadt fahren
das heißt noch mal das möglich ist und
dass man in lobberich verschwendet
sondern mir sicher sie dass das
verfahren die conti beinhaltet dass man
das album scream kennen und auf den dax
bei der umsatzsteuer damit gleich viele
der bruchsaler die umstrukturierung
produktiven schaffen das zahle sich
nicht genau sagen
[Applaus]
mit der effizienteren produktion will
swiss tools kosten einsparen und so
entlassungen vermeiden
[Applaus]
die wirklich sehr unter druck aber
interessant wie sich omega die chance
partner bewusst in china japan ab sofort
in japan und südkorea und ich sehe
natürlich das ganz europa orientiere
möglich ist auch eine sicherstellung und
dass ich abends der wettbewerb ist und
du braucht genau die ganz konkreten plan
wie global protection verzweifelt
jetzt stehen die schweren maschinen hier
wenige kilometer vom hauptsitz entfernt
made in switzerland ist unantastbar
zur frage und jetzt die zukunft zu
treffen dass sein stück woody harrelson
den installierten überschritten wenn man
sich gedanken dazu kommen aber das
gesicht diskussion habe sich sehr
optimistisch dass wir müssen wachsen
umsatz generieren und besser selber
komponiert was mit arbeitsplatzabbau
der wirtschaftsweise und leben potenzial
zu max
ein angespannter christian holz kann
er muss die belegschaft informieren über
etwas was niemand gerne tut
ich beginne mit dem geschäftsgang der es
ag diese grafik kennen sie wir liegen
aktuell umsatzmäßig bei 65 millionen per
ende august und damit liegen wir drei
prozent unter budget das ist nicht das
was wir eigentlich
aber das ist etwas was wir so auch noch
verkraften können da spreche ich den
bereich solutions und die sind ebenfalls
sehr gut unterwegs und die haben ein
großes projekt im waldgut segment das
jetzt die nun serie geht und später die
produktion gehen wird und da sprechen
wir vor allem bereit von nahezu zwei
millionen schweizer franken umsatz das
ist ein toller auftrag
anders sieht die situation im mittel 1
aus und sie sehen dass wir hier zu
beginn eigentlich noch analog vorjahr
waren aber jetzt langsam möglich da
abdriften
und jetzt muss ich sie leider in
vermieden dass wir aufgrund dieser
situation die abendschicht in der metal
ein abbauen müssen und dass sie fünf
personen deswegen abbauen werden das
berührt mich sehr und ich bin eigentlich
trotz aller bemühungen ist es uns noch
nicht gelungen diese trendwende
einzuleiten und ich bedauere es sehr
dass sie diesen schritt machen müssen
es betrifft sehr gute mitarbeiterinnen
und das betrifft auch leute die lange
dauer sind ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und steht für fragen zur
verfügung
[Applaus]
gibt es fragen aus der runde
sie können auch jederzeit später bei mir
vorbeikommen wenn sie wenn es fragen
gibt oder gehen sie auf die mt
mitglieder zu die sind auch im bild oder
kommen sie vorbei ich bin gerne bereit
die fragen zu beantworten
herzlicher dank grafischer schönen tag
und machen
man kann die persönlich in der jeder
person schauergeschichte
familiengeschichte und zu bieten und sie
schämen schwede kann man nicht bis zum
boden schicken sind die nach wie vor
richtig fit in lausanne die händehygiene
code wo er den bereich protection
beschluss wie es schon viel mohammed
braucht es müssten sich stärker um
produkte zu entwickeln
als wir endlich personal portfolio
vorstände streichen
durchaus aber selbstverständlich
einmalig muss entsorgt werden
bevor wir jetzt doch der könig
druckmaschinenhersteller wasser
spezialisiert hat für folie gedruckt und
mehr machen für die maschine löste damit
das druckerzeugnis coworker und wir
waren jetzt ein neues produkt die führer
so verteilt dass es eines led
technologie hat den luftraum 30 euro
mehr rücksicht auf sie die maschine
breite gerät und heute bei led
technologie 60 80.000 im moment zwischen
gleiche wie vorher
wieso verdienter stehenden längen ist
etwa fünf prozent wir haben morgens
leben schwierig ist euro wert ist hängt
es von der leyen alleine von der
techniker das ist das thema heute da
außer im fall vom 8
auch etwa 17 prozent teurer geworden
sind
trotz höheren preis kanton her
schließlich doch noch verkaufen
während der auftrag an der realisierung
der angepriesene realisieren muss
vorschlag einen unserer fahne will man
ein innovatives produkt vorgestellt
haben
für der maschine hersteller jetzt zwei
kriterien war sehr wichtig sind
einer sitzt gleichmäßige liegt dass das
keinen schatten hat uns zum zweiter muss
der leuchte mit lösungsmittel reinig
pause
und wenn sie zum beispiel politikern
oder sauce haben dann wird das blind des
kunststoffes
auch swiss tools intensiviert die
kundenkontakte die qualität wird in der
fabrik vor demonstriert
wenn der wirt sound werkzeugen schub
erhofft und die sieht die druck
benötigte müsste mit unserer qualität
mit dem wahlversprechen heute
schlussendlich berufsjahr mit dem
schraubenzieher oder vorträge
gutmenschen und erhält so wenn die
pension geld das ist das versprechen das
ist das um ich garantiere und damit
setze mich jeden tag dafür ist dass wir
die qualität und die mieter oder
qualitätsvorsprung zu anderen frachter
hatte ryser schäppi abteilung mal
klassik griff das granulat ag zerstört
aber das macht und das ist das cellulose
material mit bunten gesetzt der grund
das runter durch unsere die bonitäts
durch zusätze der fotoschau verstehen
kann und darum ist
hier im betrieb weniger tun um die
grippe stinkt das polizei noch das
andere
und wer über nacht mit wie verschiedene
euro beim berufs probiert die
ausgewiesene mission und ich mache mir
aber dass man ihr aroma einer gemischt
wonach eine idee der produktion
[Musik]
also schätze es natürlich so etwas mehr
als das familienunternehmen ein
gehaltener hand das wort verstanden wird
was man braucht also sich als vorstands
grundverständnis für die und nahm ich
natürlich vorhanden
das führt dazu dass wir sehr schnell
reagieren und entscheid als sehr schnell
weltweit und das zeigen nicht nur die
letzten zwei jahren das wahrscheinlich
schon seit längerem an so dass wir bei
mir ist zukunftsorientiert bewegt dass
man sehr schnell da die nötigen
entscheidungen im ganzen
das hilft natürlich enorm dass
motivierten morden schafft das stechen
mal ist man sagen haben sind auf dem
richtigen weg um ein treffen zu machen
das ist macht auch spaß das motiviert
haben
das sieht schon mal sehr gut sehr gut
also so prominent sind wir nirgends
vertreten
ein jahr nach beginn der bauarbeiten die
neue fabrikhalle ist bezugsbereit
also da muss sich schnell nach hinten
[Musik]
also ich bin so etwas von ihm überzeugt
dass das der richtige schritt war jetzt
wo es fertig ist noch mehr
das meint das ist was ist das ist
zukunft
der bereich um rollo kinderchor in dem
bereits bereits magnus wo man sie mit
eur mumbai wo man sich trifft und so
ärgert stellen war das ein anderer
stelle genau versteht und ist nicht auf
dem mond
mein trio anlage für den homo hält damit
der gunst ganz einfach sichtbar wird was
man verändern reduzieren die komplexität
der 42 das heißt am ende einer
personalreduktion kommen 450 stellen
prozent reduziert
die aber könne dort pensionäre oder
wechseln können
das resultat ist eigentlich mehr
erzielen mit dem ministaat rund 250
zuschauer sind sie von dem ganzen ausmaß
da blieb das sind rund 30 maschinen
stunden drehten kapazitäten
wir sind jetzt gut ausgelastet daher
wollte grund uns lustig
die schranken schockt rücktritts
tourismus die schweizer preise um acht
prozent reduziert
die ausländische konkurrenz sitzt ihr im
nacken
seit einem taxibus für münster volker
und das ist natürlich schmerzhaft frauen
die perspektive dass mir hey ruhe und
muße wittere investieren sie technologie
zweiter sie die ganz auf unsere
infrastruktur und zweitens sei die
voraussetzung etwas braucht für notieren
nur so kann sie großkunden wie philippe
pfister behalten
pfister führt mehrere große handwerker
einkaufszentren die günstigeren
ausländischen werkzeughersteller
bedrängen swiss tools
version wachse kurs wo man den gang zum
prozessbeginn klar mit dem mit dem
meriva schock mit der januar mit welt
wenn dann der stoß gerade im moment
sowieso die unsicherheit druckguss
rabatt mehrsprachig ausdruck für hunde
hat massiv sorgen kann
die produktion ist nach der schweiz da
haben wir im schnitt gerade so fragt
paula im jahr 2015 und das ist möglich
sind taxifahrer fajardo schweiz mit über
zügigkeit handle richtiger unterstütze
das mixed wettbewerb und europa aus dem
deutschen raum ist das natürlich sehr
attraktiver und damit einen europäische
hier in der schweiz marktanteile zu
gewinnen und mit rücksicht zu verfassen
im prinzip das runde bonus quartal ich
seitlich bis an die 20 15
es sind nicht nur chaos ist aber kein
muss natürlich insbesondere nicht nur
die exportierenden kmu sondern gott
hohem niveau im inland zulieferer sind
vor der industrie vor exportierenden
unternehmen nur die hand mit dem
schlagen die maschen druck gespürt so
umgangen wir gott wieder mit diego
langfristige vertrag hat oder sogar
angeboten der vergangenheit stetig
vorgestellt wie ihr goldener mit themen
beschäftigt 1000 voll durchsetzen und ja
eigentlich letzte ordnung abgemacht
haben
oder muss die bereits einige größen
kulanz zeigen
friede stellen hofer zukunft und das
hätte kosten mancher massigen enormen
druck ausgelöst
auf die ganze wirtschaft die jetzt heute
ist mal zur produktionsstandort der
schottergrube viel geht es wieder
aufwärts
die hand ist noé fokussierten wir sehen
die die innovation heinrichs enorm
verstärkt und das wird ein kaltes bier
auftrag eine chemie titel einsteigt hand
dass das ist nicht den bereich wo
mehrere großverdiener steht als sprich
wir sind in der automobilindustrie im
zusammenhang mit der elektronischen
fahrzeug statik also mit
batteriemanagement und sowie das sind
themen immer mehr für die hier
produzierte elektro bestandteile
versteht ja jahr lag die optisch einiges
effizienter mit den hörer ab sie lockt
die gleiche die gleiche mann als
produzieren und einfügen durchlaufzeit
zu investitions volumen runde million
xxi
zusätzliche strahlung von den höchsten
technologie sicher präzise bestückt ist
die präzise was geht das wahrscheinlich
der wettbewerbsvorteil haben ein sehr
großer vorteil dass sie sehr einfach zu
bedienen ist auch zum programmieren dass
man viel effizienter ein toller betrüger
das heißt ein buch oder weniger
betriebspersonal der wachstumsmarkt für
uns und das personal vorlage bedeutet
das kommando stil setzte der tormann
zusätzlichen auftrag ab und es sind
andere aufgaben machen die flexibilität
mitbringen
[Musik]
die nationalbank sieht wieder licht am
horizont
die allmähliche verbesserung des
internationalen umfelds kommt auch der
schweiz zugute
die erholung der exporte dürfte sich
fortsetzen
bisher war die positive entwicklung zu
einem wesentlichen teil von den
ausfuhren der pharmazeutischen industrie
getrieben
mit dem allmählichen festigung der
internationalen konjunktur dürfte die
erholung auch andere branchen erfassen
seit jahresbeginn haben auch die exporte
von maschinen präzisionsinstrumenten und
metall war wieder etwas zugelegt die
beschäftigungsaussichten haben sich
zuletzt etwas aufgehellt
wir rechnen mit einer stabilisierung der
arbeitslosenquote in der zweiten
jahreshälfte mit export als ganzes album
ist fröhlich aber wenn wir nie verloren
das habe frau und pharmaindustrie
möglichen ganze starker motorisch
exportindustrie das passt so stimmt aber
dass ich gott gerade maschinenindustrie
das ist ein auto stark an der stoßzeit
und das wäre heute niveau sind peter und
maschinenindustrie und die wachsen dass
man homburgs quartal ist die rückläufige
und auf einem niveau wächst und gemäß
der verwaltungsberufe niveau von 2003
das wachstum ist also was ist das
relativ einfach die regie von hal jordan
nicht ganz teilen
und ich glaube auch nicht dass es in der
elektrotechnik und der maschinenbau
genau wirklich positiv verläuft wie es
beispielsweise in der chemie verläuft
das ist ja auch unterstrich erwarte dass
chemie gewisse zuwachsraten
und zum anderen ist china relativ einer
talsohle nennen und nicht zuletzt auch
der ölpreis definitiv das bereitet
kopfzerbrechen selbstverständlich umso
mehr dass man sie 2005 als widerstand
bei öl und gasindustrie aufbauten und
jetzt total bei schwierigkeiten unsere
produkte verkaufen will gesellschaft
aufgrund von jefferies ihre
investitionen vollständig stoppen
ich möchte unsere verträge neuwagen in
der vergangenheit sehr gut geschafft
macht in norwegen wird
explosionsgeschützte heutige ansbach
castor umstrukturierung unsere letzte
vertrat eine andere erwartungen nicht
und trinkt und atelier zu machen
neugierig im explosionsschutz und wir
haben viele jahre zusammen gefunden dass
man die firma war neulich durch unsere
produkt vertreten 2007 an land
kuba ist ein familienunternehmen
wir existieren seit 84 jahren mein
großvater hat die firma 1932 gegründet
wir starten mit elektrischen heizungen
als ich in die firma eintrat war mein
ziel dass 70 prozent unserer produkte
explosions geschützt sind
heute sind wir bei 99 99
ich glaube das ist das wichtigste das
man natürlich herzen also durch strecken
möglichst viel unternimmt damit wir noch
eine bereit ist wenn es wieder losgeht
[Musik]
auch swiss tools will die durststrecke
nutzen und aktiv kunden werben ein
entfernen in köln für kunden und
wiederverkäufer
[Musik]
ok
sie ist von der inneren mit regal muss
was ich vertragsbruch mit am globalen
wettbewerb wieder kurz positionieren und
das räumen investieren und wieder in die
innovationskraft auf euren lieber hatte
ashley informiert über eine wichtige
neuerung bistums werkzeuge sind künftig
auch online bestellbar
im fokus von der mem industrie über die
ganze metallverarbeitung maschinenbau
ohren sowie zugehört wird die beim
formulieren der herrlich entspannen
gesicht das heißt mit großer handlung
hat das größenwachstum schwaches
wachstum aber das war es dann auch
auslöser war der mit das dürfte sie dann
esse ich sie aussieht vorjahresperiode
aber jetzt muss man auch knallhart
workers filling exportsituation nach wie
vor sehr ausdrucksvoll
entsprechend nach unten korrigiert hat
auch die nationalbank ihre prognose
habe man trotz der relativ günstigen
entwicklung die wir jetzt im aggregat
haben die schwierigkeiten einige
sektoren und die anpassung des starken
frankens nicht unterschätzen also wir
haben ganze reihe von sektoren die
weitere eigentliche unter dem starken
franken leiden ist nicht durch die
mem-industrie sind andere sektoren die
ebenfalls unter dieser situation leiden
es ist beeindruckend wenn man sieht wie
viele unternehmen sich diese schwierigen
situation gut schlagen aber auf der
anderen seite muss man auch sehen dass
diese herausforderung das vor der
weltweiten groß sind diese
herausforderungen sind auch deshalb groß
weil wir natürlich mitten im euroraum
sind wo sehr viele der wettbewerber
diese firmen durch mit ganz andere
währungsverhältnissen konfrontiert sind
was dass die schweizerischen firmen sind
das von dem eher glaube ich ist es
wichtig dass wir den fokus auf diesen
exkurs zu verlegen
immerhin die drei familien unternehmen
haben die krise genutzt um sich neu zu
positionieren
ja jetzt 340 europa league auf deinen
job und ich habe schon immer k
ich bin als junger menschen in krisen
die nach 3 70 74 waren sie in den 80er
jahren kam und vom grundsatz her das
mitmachen es immer geschafft mit einem
wieder zugang und das ist vielleicht
ganz untypisch für viele schweizer crm
usw
ich tue es aber gott erklärt sie dass
man sehr aktiv sie das mir also ist sehr
gut so zieht heute entscheiden wo
relativ große tragen sind und also
härter ich denke dass man das gut regeln
erwirtschaftet der letzten jahre nach
der finanzkrise
das mandat sei verständliche sätze für
die führende position landwirt aus der
praxis transporter und das bedingt dass
mit einer phase wie es wirklich hart
investieren damit wir im richtigen
moment werde die innovationskraft hat
und damit auch im markt auftreten
[Musik]
red und dozenten mit ihm vor mehrere
dutzend gäste der widrigen verkauft
haben und zwar mir sind somit rund 108
glüht in tschechien wo man komponenten
demontieren um handys verkauft mit hoher
kompetenz für den touch panels an petrus
bauen also das heißt dass man den
betrieb aber system größer war schon
viermal mit rund 2 und mitarbeiter wo
man drauf dass wir dort rechts platz die
schweizer wahrscheinlich vor der
fotogruppe das ist niedrig waren
natürlich nicht einen akquisition am
marktanteil gefunden und das stand im
vordergrund
auch die ausbau des bisherigen
tschechischen werks ist beendet ralf
müller auf inspektion
das ist zu schön ist auch dass
das zugenommen
perfekt größere geschrieben
[Musik]
im 2005 zwei zusätzliche gleise betreten
vom gewinn bricht weg nach einem schluss
zu wissen ob sie also mit sehen
der umstand entsprechend zufrieden mit
dem resultat sehr zufrieden und da muss
ich natürlich in erster linie franz
enderli meter breiten dem unternehmen
weiter zu betreiben wir haben ja diverse
profit macht das mehr an diverse pakete
geschnürt wo sehr schnell haben wir es
ab arbeitet wahrte im unternehmen zum
teil auf globale aktivitäten und das ist
ein gefallener sehr gut und mit welcher
disziplin gemacht wurde
mehr haben den klassiker vor knapp sind
jedem konkreter von fünf mitarbeitern
dixie also mehr hand präsentiert unter
dem lager wo mir ein kritisches szenario
führungsrolle tand und rennsport einer
ruhezeit sein fuß gegangen sind
aber mit fünf mitarbeitern der nächste
sein können
ich würde einen vertrag bekommen
die anderen dass jetzt schluss sein dazu
geführt dass mehr mit dem hellblauen
sind und vor allem machtkämpfe zukunft
[Musik]